THIS WAS A HUGE, IMPORTANT KEY
PSYCHOLOGICAL MOVE.
BRET, BACK TO YOU.
>> Bret: DEIRDRE, THANK YOU.
CHINA SAYS IT WILL REVOKE THE
CREDENTIALS OF AMERICANS AT
THREE U.S. NEWSPAPERS IN
RESPONSE TO NEW U.S.
RESTRICTIONS ON CHINESE MEDIA.
THE FOREIGN MINISTRY WANTS
JOURNALISTS WORKING FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"WALL STREET JOURNAL," AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST"’S
CREDENTIALS ARE DUE TO EXPIRE
BEFORE THE END OF 2020 TO HAND
BACK THERE PRESS CARDS WITHIN
TEN DAYS.
THAT MOVES COMES AFTER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DESIGNATED FIVE
CHINESE MEDIA OUTLETS AS FOREIGN
MISSIONS AND RESTRICTED THE
NUMBER OF CHINESE WHO COULD WORK
FOR THEM.
LATE TODAY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CALLED THE
DECISION YET ANOTHER STEP TOWARD
DEPRIVING THE CHINESE PEOPLE AND